Hey. Hey. Hey.
Tonight's lecture is entitled Changing
the Word. And this is quite a serious
topic and people get very excited about
it because everybody has a favorite
Bible. The one says the NIV is the
greatest Bible that he could possibly
have read. The other one has another
one. The other one has the New King
James. Somebody likes the old King
James. Which one is the right Bible?
Now, personally, I came into a knowledge
of the word of God using the NIV Bible.
And I found God in the NIV and through
the NIV. And that is fine. But as you
grow in your Christian experience, you
might want to find out the differences
that exist in the world. And for that,
you need doctrine. And in the Bible, it
says that the Bible is good for reproof
and for doctrine. And uh Timothy tells
us that we should take heed of the
doctrine. So doctrine is important that
we may know what the word of God exactly
tells us.
When it comes to the finer nuances, if
you do not have doctrine and you cannot
tell the differences, well then
everything can be the same. And
basically what you have then is an
ecumenical Bible. Changing the word.
Revelation 22:18
says, "For I testify unto every man that
heareth the words of the prophecy of
this book. If any man shall add unto
these things, God shall add unto him the
plagues that are written in the book. If
any man shall take away from the words
of the book of the prophecy, God shall
take away his part out of the book of
life and out of the holy city and from
the things which are written in this
book. Now, we discussed this yesterday.
And this is a serious matter to mess and
meddle with the word of God.
I thought you know I'll give you a
little resume a few books that are
generally available to the public that
are good to read as far as this is
concerned. Our authorized Bible
Vindicated by Wilkinson is quite a good
little book. It's quite old already.
Came out in 1930 and it's being
reprinted.
Which Bible can we trust? By Les Garrett
is a very good book to read in regard to
this. New age Bible versions by Dr.
Riplinger is also full of information.
So there are a number of books that one
can get that can help us along the way
to find out which version is the one
that we should trust.
Verses affected in the Bibles. A rough
count would give us the New American
Standard Bible 99 verses. That's a lot.
The Revised Version, 788 verses. The New
World Translations 767, the NIV 695.
The Good News Bible 614, the Amplified
484, the Dua, which is the Jesuit Bible,
has fewer changes than the New American
Standard. In fact, less than half.
Amazing. And the Reformation, of course,
rejected this completely, but they're
quite happy to accept these ones. Very
strange. The old Jehovah's Witness Bible
only had 120 verses affected. And when
that came out, there was a huge human
cry over the massive changes that they
made. And today, nobody realizes that
they're sitting with 99 verses affected,
which makes the 120 look like
kindergarten.
the New King James Version and ignored
the text asus receptus 1,200
times.
Now, I quite like the New King James
Version and I I use it for myself, but I
have it marked everywhere where it
irritates me. For example, everywhere
where the Bible says where Jesus is the
son, the New King James prefers to put
servant. That puts a totally different
spin on the ball. The word Lord is
removed 66 times at least and so on and
so forth. But uh I'm more interested
tonight in concentrating on these where
the changes are really blatant. And uh
there are steps from bad to worse as we
can see.
Jehovah's Witness Bible is the first one
that was changed. Now, this was early in
the 1900s when when Westcot and Hort had
produced their documents. They didn't
have their own Bible because up to the
1900s there was no other version except
the Jesuit one which had been rejected
totally by the Reformation.
So, let's just see what they did. We're
just going to run through it. Imagine
you are all getting a Bible in your
hands, a King James version Bible, and
you're given a black pen, and you're
told, "Cross out." This is what they
would have done. That's exactly what
happened in the early Jehovah's Witness
Church because that's the only Bible
they had before they printed their own.
And then they started changing it.
Matthew 16 verse3 for example if we go
from there onwards you'll see they
removed that one irrespective of what
that text means I'll show you later in
the others that everything that was
changed in the Jehovah's Witness Bible
has also been changed in the other
Bibles or at least discredited in the
margin if nothing else.
So they took uh Matthew 16:E3 out. When
it came to the book of Mark, they took
verse 46 out. They had to cross it out.
When it came to Mark 16 9-20, well, they
just took out the whole chapter
because why? Because here Jesus appears
physically
after the resurrection. And that is a
problem. You see the esoteric world
teaches that there is no physical
resurrection. It is esoteric and a
physical Jesus having raised been raised
from the dead is a problem. So take out
the chapter and modify the chapters
other than Mark that are not quite as
blatant on the issue. So if you have one
of the modern translations, it will at
least say in the margin that this is not
found in the oldest manuscripts. But as
we saw, the oldest manuscripts were
already corrupt because they had the
modifications of Oregon as we will see
John 1 verse one in the New World
Translation. That's the the the Bible of
the Jehovah's Witnesses as they have
written it. It says there in the
beginning the word was and the word was
with God and the word was a god.
Whereas the king James says in the
beginning was the word and the word was
with god and the word was god. So
obviously Jesus was God in the King
James but uh he was a lesser being if
you like with a lowercase G when it
comes to the uh new world translation.
Then when it comes to John chapter 1 11
chapter 8 11 up to verse 11 the whole
series just gone. Just take a pen ladies
and gentlemen cross it out. We no need
it no longer. We have found something
better. Acts 8:37 in the Jehovah's
Witness Bible is of course removed
because there Jesus is the only way to
be saved away with that text. You'll
find it missing in the others as well. 1
John 5:7 is a major problem because
they're here Jesus is part of the
godhood gone. We'll come to that in the
others as well. So that's what Jehovah's
Witnesses did. They just took their pens
and they crossed out all these relevant
verses and whole portions of chapters
and whole chapters and there was a huge
human cry about it. Now imagine that the
Bibles that we have today
do more than that and nobody complains.
Isn't that strange? Isn't that strange
how we have changed? Dublin Review 1881.
By the sole authority of textual
criticism,
not in other words by the word itself,
not what it says, but by textual
criticism.
These men have dared to vote away some
40 verses of the inspired word. This was
early. Now, as you see, hundreds of
verses are affected. The Uno's baptismal
profision of faith is gone, and the
angel of the pool of Bethesa has
vanished. But the angel of the agony
remains till the next revision. The
heavenly witnesses have departed and no
marginal note mourns their lost. The
last 12 verses of St. Mark are detached
from the rest of the gospel as if ready
for removal as soon as Dean Bergen dies.
Remember I quoted a lot from Dean Bergen
yesterday when he goes they said well
they're going to change a lot more and
they surely have. The account of the
woman taken in adultery is placed in
brackets awaiting excision.
Many other passengers have a mark set
against them in the margin to show that
like forest trees they are shortly
destined for the critics's acts. Who can
tell when the destruction will cease?
That was in 1881 when they just started
revising the Bible. Isn't that
incredible?
Well, let's see what the modern people
say. This is what modern Bible societies
say. No testamentum gi the German Bible
society.
What has that got to say? It says when I
Nestle in 1898 presented the first
edition of No Testament Gai. He had
achieved a work of which the
consequences were not only unknown to
him at the time but also to the
Vertonborg Bible Society that made the
addition possible. If the text receptus
at that time still had a number of
defenders, the science,
note that the science of the 19th
century had, however, finally proved it
to be the worst text of the New
Testament. So the Bible, the text
receptus that had stood the test of time
until 1900 now suddenly was the worst
text available.
There the additions of Tishonorf that's
the man who discovered that piece of
rubbish in a waste paper basket on which
all the modern Bibles are based since
1841 finalized edition of such and such
and such and such and Westcot and Hort
came in 1881
controlled the field but in practical
terms at the level of the university
church school the addition of the texus
receptus
was still largely used internationally
as for example by the British Bible
Society until 1904
irrespective of the changes the British
didn't change that easily only with the
release of the Nestle text
and did the rule of the texus receptors
come to an end here also much rejoicing
in Roman Catholic circles that finally
managed to destroy the texus receptus
The encyclopedia bratannica tells us
something about Oregon. We'll see in a
moment. The received text, the text
receptus is the old Bzantine text with
hundreds of copies in agreement. It was
written in coin Greek. Note that written
in coin Greek of which hundreds of words
cannot be translated into classical
Greek. The early church used coined
Greek manuscripts and rejected the
Alexandrian versions which were based on
the corrupt versions which Oregon and
other gnostic revisions.
Now the encyclopedia Britannica tells us
that Oregon taught that Jesus was a
created being who did not have eternal
existence as God. So that's the basis.
If you want to have an ecumenical Bible,
you have to remove Jesus Christ as the
sole savior and as God. It has to be
done.
So I thought we would go to morals and
dogma which is of course the freemason
source. This doctrine of transmigration
of souls, in other words, reincarnation
that you come again and again and again,
obtained as Paulrey informs us amongst
the Persians and the Mari, the magicians
if you like. Herodotus
believed this, the Egyptians believed
this, the Kurds believed it, the Chinese
believed it. And so Oregon held this
doctrine. There you have it. All these
esoteric ideas, Oregon had them, and
Bishious Bishop Sinius, the latter of
whom had been initiated, and who thus
prayed to God, "Oh, Father, grant that
my soul reunited to the light may not be
plunged again into the defilement of
Earth, reincarnation." In other words,
so the Gnostics held, they held this
belief just like the Hindus do today.
And even the disciples of Christ
inquired if the man who was born blind
was not so punished for some sin that he
had committed before his birth.
Now that's typical how Freemasons
distort the word. Did the disciples
inquire that? Let's ask them. John 9
verse two. And his disciple asked him
saying, "Master, who did sin? this man
or his parents that he was born blind.
Not this man in this life or in his
previous life, right?
Or his parents. So, you know, everything
is a distortion. You cannot trust
anything these people say. Well, he
knows who the esoterics are. And I said
that the early church had already been
corrupted. And Paul said as many as
corrupt the word of God even in his day.
Oregon morals and dogma page 544 born AD
134. So this is right there in the
beginning
answering Celsius who had objected that
the Christians had a concealed doctrine
said in as much as the essential and
important doctrines and principles of
Christianity are openly taught. It is
foolish to object that there are other
things that are recondite. In other
words, they are not taught. For this is
common to Christian discipline with that
of those philosophers in whose teaching
some things were exoteric for the
outside world and some esoteric for the
brilliant initiative initiated ones and
it is enough to say that it was so with
some of the disciples of Pythagoras. So
here he's talking about initiation
insiders being initiated.
So Oregon believed in two doctrines, one
for the outside, one for the inside. So
he was an oultist.
Morrison and dogma continues, Oregon
gives much information as to the
mysteries of the ofites and there is no
doubt that all the gnostic sects had
mysteries and an initiation. So here was
a secret doctrine that came into the
churches. They all claim to possess a
secret doctrine coming to them directly
from Jesus Christ different from that of
the gospels and epistles and superior to
these communications. So there was the
insider who just knew a little bit more
and superior which in their eyes were
merely exoteric. So the gospels are for
the stupid people and the inside
information is for the brilliant ones.
continue with morals and dogma to find
out who these early apostate church
fathers were that were rejected by the
early church. By the way, uh they were
open to the fidelis, the fides, the
faithful only. Remember that the Roman
Catholic Church has this woman with a
cup mystery written on her head and the
cup underneath it says fides which is
also a dedication to a goddess as we did
in a previous lecture. Uh, Tertullian,
there's one of the church fathers who
died about AD 216, says in his apology,
"None are admitted to the religious
mysteries without an oath of secrecy.
We appeal to our Tracian and Illusian
mysteries, and we are especially bound
to this caution because if we prove
faithless, we should not only provoke
heaven, but draw upon our heads the
utmost rigor of human displeasure.
And should strangers betray us? They
knew nothing but report and hearsay. For
hence ye profane, hence ye profane is
the prohibition from all holy mysteries.
So we are the profane. Get your hence
you stupid ones. We are the initiated
ones. We know. Then there's another one.
So that was Tertillian. He was a corrupt
bishop AD 260. We get it straight from
the Masonic source. Then there was
Clemens, bishop of Alexandria. Well, we
would expect an Alexandrian bishop to be
corrupt. Born about AD 191. So there's
an early bishop. Says in his stroa that
he cannot explain the mysteries because
he should thereby according to the old
proverb put a sword in the hands of a
child. So now what have you been called
so far? profane,
a child,
uninitiated,
ignorant. Well, here's Sirill, bishop of
Jerusalem, was born in the year 315,
died 386. This also comes from morals
and dogma. In his catechesus, he says,
"The Lord spoke in parables to his
heroes in general. But to his disciples,
he explained in private the parables and
allegorories which he spoke in public.
The splendor of glory is for those who
are early enlightened." So only those
get the enlightenment. Obscurity and
darkness are the portion of the
unbelievers and the ignorant. Wow.
Just so the church discovers its
mysteries to those who have advanced
beyond the class of cateumans.
Here's another word for you. Catacumans.
I'm so proud. I belong to the
catacumans.
We employ obscure terms with others. So
the dumb ones don't get the truth. Only
the initiated get the truth. Well, what
does Matthew say about parables 13:35?
that it might be fulfilled which was
spoken by the prophet saying, "I will
open my mouth in parables.
I will utter things which have been kept
secret from the foundation of the
world." So the parables are to reveal,
not to obscure. And they say the
parables are to obscure and not to
reveal.
Now, here's a famous uh bishop, St.
Augustine. As you all know, St.
Augustine is the founding father if you
like of Catholicism who was born 347
died 430 says in one of his dis
discourses having dismissed the catumans
hence ye katakumans go away
we have retained you only to be our
hearers how nice thank you for that
privilege because besides those things
which belong to all Christians in common
we are now to discord course to you of
sublime mysteries which none are
qualified to hear but those who by the
master's favor are made partakers of
them. So Jesus will choose some for his
favor and the rest are cutumans. Go away
we'll just tell you what you think you
should hear. To have taught them openly
would have been to betray them. How
nice. Isn't this deceptive?
This is disgusting.
St. Chesterton and St. Augustine speaks
of initiation more than 50 times. St.
Ambrose wrote rights to those who are
initiated and initiation was not merely
baptism or admission into the church.
But it referred to initiation into the
mysteries morals and dogma page 4 546.
That's from the horse's mouth. You
cannot get a better source than that.
Then what does he say about Christ the
storm bishop of Constantinople?
That's the other place where the corrupt
uh versions originated. He was born 354,
died 417. He says, "I wish to speak
openly, but I dare not on account of
those who are not initiated." Oh,
brother, here's another one. So, was the
early church full of corrupt bishops
already? Yes or no? Absolutely.
I shall therefore avail myself of
disguising terms, discoursing in a
shadowy manner
where the holy mysteries are celebrated.
We drive away all uninitiated persons
and then close the doors.
These people do things in darkness. He
mentions the acclamation of the
initiated which he says I hear Passover
in silence for it is forbidden to
disclose such things to the profane.
You're cathumans. You're profane. You're
uninitiated. What are we still?
Well, KL Marx calls us cattle,
human herds.
Sincer of Alexandria. I like the way
they always are saints. Saints of who?
who made bishop in 412 and died in 444
says in the seventh book against Julian
these mysteries are so profound and so
exalted that they can be comprehended by
those only who are enlightened
we fortunate that there are some
enlightened ones on the world who know
what's going on the rest of us can just
stay stupid
well what does the Bible say about these
secret initiations S Isaiah 45:1 19 I
have not spoken in secret in a dark
place of the earth. I said not unto the
seed of Jacob, seek ye me in vain. I the
Lord speak righteousness. I declare
things that are right. Oh, that sounds
nice. I like that. Isaiah 48:16. Come ye
near unto me. Hear ye this. I have not
spoken in secret from the beginning.
from the time that it was there I am and
now the Lord God and his spirit has sent
me. No secrets with God. Amos 3:7.
Surely the Lord God will do nothing but
he reveals his secret unto the servants,
the prophets.
Mark 4:22, let's go to the New
Testament. For there is nothing hid
which shall not be manifested, neither
was anything kept secret, but that it
should come abroad.
Luke 8:17, for nothing is secret. There
shall not be made manifest, neither
anything hid that shall not be known and
come abroad.
Luke 11:33, "No man, when he hath
lighted a candle, put it in its secret
place, neither under a bushel, but on a
candlestick, that they which come in may
see the lights."
John 7:4. For there is no man that doeth
anything in secret, and he himself
seeketh to be known openly. If thou do
these things, show thyself to the world.
Which doctrine do you prefer?
those of the enlightened enlightened
initiated ones or those of the Bible?
Which God would you prefer to serve? The
God of the initiated ones or the God of
the Bible? I like this one. I like Jesus
Christ. Let me tell you what Jesus said.
John 18:20.
Jesus answered him and him, I spake
openly to the world. I ever taught in
the synagogue and in the temple whether
the Jews always resort and in secret I
have said nothing.
Which god do you prefer? I prefer this
one. I hate this secrecy.
This clandestine
religion. This I know more than you
story. Isn't it disgusting?
I know the path and I don't care if you
don't make it. You're just a catacum.
Well, let's have a look how they changed
it. These initiated ones to keep the
truth away from the rest of the world.
Which verses did they change? We know
they changed them. Let's just have a few
easy ones and then we'll get deeper and
deeper into the doctrine. Remember a few
things. Remember
that Hort said we will change it very
slightly. Hear a word, there a word, and
nobody will even notice. And finally,
when we have it all together, when we
have all the little changes in one big
package, if you read it all together,
our doctrine and not theirs will be
there. Isn't that what he said? That's
exactly what he said. So, NIV 2 Samuel
21:19. In another battle with the
Philistines at Goblahin, son of Yurakum,
the Bethlehem, the might killed Goliath,
the Gitite, who had a spear with a shaft
like a weaver's rod. Oops. Who killed
him?
Ilan, son of Yare Orim, King James. And
there was again a battle in Gob with the
Philistines where Elan the son of same
one a Bethleamite slew the brother of
Goliath the Gitite the staff of whose
spear was like a weaver's beam who did
kill Goliath.
>> Oh, so you prefer the King James version
over the other one over the NIV.
2 Samuel 23:5 NIV is not my house right
with God. King James version, although
my house be not so with God. So they
turn everything around. When God says
it's not right, the NIV says that he's
right.
Another one, Hosea 11:12, and Judah is
unruly against God, even against the
faithful holy one. King James, but Judah
yet ruleth with God, and is faithful
with the saints. You see, God had said,
Ephraim has left me. Israel has left me,
but Judah is still with me. Satan
doesn't like that. So he says, "No, all
of them were against me." So he changed
that, too. There's a little change.
It's, you know, it's minor, but it it's
quite important. You're either with God
or you're against God. Matthew 5:44. But
I say to you, love your enemies and pray
for those who persecute you. Revised
Standard Version, King James Version.
But I say unto you, love your enemies,
bless them that curse you, do good to
them that hate you, and pray for them
which despitefully use you, and
persecute you. Well, let's just take
that out, and then uh we don't have a
full story anymore.
Matthew 8:15 11. Don't you think this is
an important text? For the son of man is
come to save that
which was lost. Don't you think that is
an important text? I think it's a very
important text. Why? Why is it gone in
the Revised Standard Version? Because
Jesus is not supposed to be the only
savior. You say, "We're supposed to save
ourselves." Didn't masonry teach that we
can save ourselves? We don't need Jesus.
That's a ridiculous teaching. He's just
an example. Matthew 2016, the Revised
Standard Version. So, the last will be
first and the first will be last. Nice.
and the King James.
So the last shall be first and the first
shall be last for many are called but
few are chosen. You see here it makes a
difference. Here it is important to
choose to choose right. Here you just
come first or last. Who cares? But here
you could be last if you don't make the
right choice. Which one do you think is
the correct one?
So away with the choice business.
Matthew chapter 20 22 and 23.
Well the NIV says you don't know what
you are asking. Jesus said to them, can
you drink the cup I'm going to drink? We
can. They answered. Nice.
Jesus said to them, you will indeed
drink from my cup, but sit at my right
or left is not for me to grant. These
places belong to those whom they have
been prepared for by my father. What
does the King James say? Jesus answered
and said, "You know not what you ask.
You are able to drink. Are you able to
drink of the cup that I shall drink of
and to be baptized with the baptism that
I am baptized with? Can you be baptized
with the baptism that I am to be
baptized with? Can you go through the
same? Can you go through suffering for
my sake?
Matthew 25:13.
Very important RSV. Watch therefore, for
you know neither the day nor the hour.
Now tell me, is that a logical text for
the God of the universe to put into the
Bible? To say, watch therefore, for you
know neither the day nor the hour. Of
what? Hello.
Of what?
Wherein the Son of Man cometh. Doesn't
that make sense? So which one is even
the more logical one? Obviously this
one. So now please note that in this one
you know neither the day nor the hour of
when the ice cream man will come along
or whatever.
But in this one it's important wherein
the son of man cometh. Now let's go a
little bit further. Notice what the NIV
does in Matthew 24:36.
No one knows about that day that we just
read about
or hour, not even the angels in heaven,
nor the son, but only the father.
Have you read that? Have you read that
text? Nor the son. What does the King
James version say? But of that day and
hour knoweth no man, no, not the angels
of heaven, but my father only. Where is
the nor the son bit? It's not there.
Now, if you take the verse where Jesus
says, "I and the father are one."
Then what does that make of this verse?
Does Jesus then know when he's coming?
Yes or no?
>> Absolutely.
But what does it imply if you put there
nor the son? It implies that Jesus is
not part of the godhood. Are you with
me? It implies that Jesus is not part of
the godhood. This is a serious change.
Mark chapter 2 verse 17. I came not to
call the righteous but sinners. How
nice. Hello sinners. Here you come to
me. This is great. The NIV. I have not
come to call the righteous but sinners.
King James. I have not come to call the
righteous but sinners to repentance.
Wow. Here there's an action. This is
ecumenical. Let's all have a party
together. It doesn't matter whether you
believe the same thing, whether you keep
the ten commandments, whatever you do.
If you believe that you can, you know,
sleep around with 50 women at the same
time, who cares? No, no, no. The King
James says to repentance. So take it
out. We don't need that. We are
initiated ones. We are above that.
Mark chapter 6 11. Now please note I'm
going through the smaller changes so
that you can see the big picture at the
end of the time. I'm not even going
through the mega changes. I'm just going
through the subtle changes where a
little bit is changed here and a little
bit is changed there. Mark 6:1.
If any place if any place will not
receive you and they refuse to hear you
when you leave, shake off the dust that
is on your feet for a testimony against
them.
What's what does the King James say? And
whosoever shall not receive you nor hear
you when you depart then shake off the
dust under your feet for a testimony
against them.
Verily I say unto you, it shall be more
tolerable for Sodom and Gomorrah in the
day of judgment than for that city. Why
do you think that verse has been
removed? Why do they remove the verse
which says it will be more tolerable for
Sodom and Gomorrah?
Because they do not believe in a
judgment.
You see the choice that you make?
Who cares? Didn't they believe in
reincarnation?
Whatever you did wrong now, who cares?
You can fix it next time round. And even
if you can't fix it next time round in
purgatory, you can burn it off. That's
fine.
So, let's take the judgment right out.
That'll solve the problem. Then we've
modified that text. Can you see how many
pieces are missing? So, I'm not talking
about whole verses here. We're just
looking at half verses and these things.
Mark 10 verse 21,
Revised Standard Version. And come
follow me, NIV. Then come follow me ASV.
Come follow me. King James. And come
take up the cross
and follow me. What's the difference
between those two?
Here is a cross to bear. When you become
a Christian, there's a change in life
and there is a cross to bear. And that
is Christianity. The other is what?
Salvation in sin. One big happy party.
Mark 10 verse 21. Why would they take
that out? Isn't it incredible? Just take
it out. Why not? Mark 10 verse 24. RSV
children. How hard it is to enter the
kingdom of God. The NIV. How hard it is
for the rich to enter the kingdom of
God. Wow. Even worse.
King James version. children. How hard
it is for them that trust in riches to
enter into the kingdom of God. What's
the difference between those two? Well,
here you might as well give up from the
beginning and rather inc reincarnate a
couple of times. Here, better not get
rich. Better give all your money away.
Here, money is not the problem. It's
making an idol of money that's a
problem. Isn't that correct? You can be
rich, but you can do a lot of good for
the Lord God. You can do a lot of good.
So, this one is the only one that makes
any sense. This one is just
discouragement. My God is a God of
encouragement, not discouragement. Take
it out. We don't need that. We need
arms. After all, if you have to keep uh
the monasteries and the nunneries going,
you better take that verse out.
Mark 13:14. But when you see the
desolated sacrilege set up where it
ought not to be,
well, this is fascinating.
But when you see the abomination, this
is King James, of desolation spoken of
by Daniel the prophet standing where it
ought not to be. Why take that out?
Because Jesus is pointing to two
specific apocalyptic books in the Bible
where we should study for the end times.
The one is the book of Daniel and the
other one is the book of revelation.
Blessed are they that read the words of
this book. It says in terms of
revelation and it says when you see this
spoken of by the prophet Daniel go and
look over there you'll find some answers
there because they were asked what is
the sign of your coming and of the end
of the age check that out in the book of
Daniel Jesus said well let's take away
the evidence just remove it they don't
like that prophecy Lukeap 2:14 revised
standard version glory to God in the
highest and on earth peace amongst men
with whom he is pleased.
King James, glory to God in the highest
and on earth peace, goodwill towards
men. Now, what's the difference between
those two? It's a very subtle change.
But what is the change?
Here there's an initiated few with whom
he is pleased. There God is for
everyone, not two classes. This is for
the initiated insider. This is for the
cacumans included. Cannot be changed.
See what I mean? It's disgusting. It's
really disgusting what they're doing
here. Luke 4:4. And it's not in harmony
with the character of God. That's the
important principle. So, it's not a
question of grammar. It's a question of
principle. Luke 4:4. And Jesus answered
him, "It is written, man shall not live
by bread alone." Revised Standard
Version, NIV.
Jesus answered, "It is written, man does
not live by bread alone." Is that right?
King James version. And Jesus answered
him, saying, "It is written that man
shall not live by bread alone, but by
every word of God."
Oops. We're changing it all. So we
better remove that or else we rebuke
ourselves. Right? So let's just take it
out. The word is not important today.
The word is just merely incidental. What
is important is what you feel.
What you feel is right. God will lead
you through his spirit. All religions
lead to the ultimate source. Trust your
feelings. Forget about the word. Isn't
that the teaching of the world today?
Isn't that what they teach?
But if you trust every word of God, you
better make sure that you know what God
wants and make the necessary changes.
2 Timothy 3:16, the ASV, every scripture
inspired of God is also profitable for
teaching. King James version, all
scripture is given by inspiration of God
and is profitable for doctrine. They
changed one little word. What's the
difference? One little word. We will
change said hort a little bit here a
little bit there and they won't even
notice it after all cateumans they're so
stupid they won't notice
what is this here only that scripture
which is inspired by God is profitable
so which is inspired and which is not
well that's for the initiator to decide
isn't it that's why the pope will tell
you what to believe and you can't just
read for yourself because then you are
heresus
You make your own choice and that is
heresy. You're subject to the penalty of
death.
All scripture is given by inspiration of
God and is profitable for doctrine. Luke
chapter 9 verse 55 and 56. Just look
what disappears. RSV. But he turned and
rebuked them and they went into another
village, the NIV. But Jesus turned and
village.
You know, besides being strange, it's
it's a stupid verse. It's stupid.
But he turned and rebuked them and said,
"Ye know not what manner of spirit you
are of. For the Son of Man is not come
to destroy men's lives, but to save
them,
and they went into another village."
Now, which one to you makes more sense?
Which one is important? Which one is
more important to you? This one has
power. This one has a savior. This one
has an answer to all your troubles.
This one has no answer whatsoever. It
might as well not be in the Bible. And I
don't believe God ever put something so
ridiculous as that in the Bible.
Luke 22 43 and 44. Gone. You won't find
it in the RSV. And there appeared an
angel unto him from heaven,
strengthening him. And being in an
agony, he prayed more earnestly, and his
sweat was, as it were, great drops of
blood falling to the ground. Why do you
think they removed that text?
Remember, they don't believe in the
atonement.
And if they don't believe in the
atonement, they don't believe that Jesus
shed one drop of blood for you
away with that disgusting doctrant of
the atonement as Hort claims.
These are serious changes. And the Lord
says that people who touch his word like
this and remove Jesus Christ from the
gospel, they're going to have to pay the
price.
John chapter 14 10:14.
I am the good shepherd. I know my own
and my own know me. King James version.
This is subtle. I am the good shepherd
and know my sheep and am known of mine.
There's a subtle difference there. All
right. In view of the next succeeding
words, as the father knoweth me, even so
know I the father. This change destroys
the exquisite diversity of expression of
the original. It makes grammatical sense
and it gives the relationship between
father and son which means that Jesus is
God. It's a subtle change to remove some
of the power of Jesus Christ.
Acts 8, Acts 28 29. Let it be known to
you then that this salvation of God has
been sent to the Gentiles. They will
listen.
And when he had said these words, the
Jews departed and had great reasoning
amongst themselves, says the King James.
Now, why does the book of Acts have to
have that removed in the RSV?
I'll tell you why.
Because when you decide for or against
this subject, it's going to be divisive.
It's going to be divisive. And they had
great reasoning amongst themselves.
But a spirit of ecommenism says
everybody come together. We are one
happy family. Here there is a spirit of
separation. Do you understand the
difference? very important difference.
So Jesus makes a difference and it's
important that we know what the Bible
teaches on this issue.
In our previous session we saw that the
gospel is divisive. So when you preach
Jesus Christ, a decision is made. The
gospel is a two-edged sword which
strikes and cuts through to the marrow
and people make a decision based on the
facts and they either move to the one
camp or the other camp.
So that is why verse 29 in an ecumenical
Bible had to go because
great reasoning and a split came.
between them. 1 Corinthians 10:28,
"But if someone says to you, this has
been offered in sacrifice, then out of
consideration for the man who informed
you, and for conscience sake, etc." King
James version, but if any may say unto
you, this is offered in sacrifice unto
idols, eat not for his sake that showed
it, and for conscience sake, for the
earth is the Lord's and the fullness
thereof. So why are there certain rules
in the Bible?
Because God owns it. And who owns it
here? The Lord. That's a reference to
Jesus Christ. So we don't want him to
own it because the esoterics remember
masonry has someone else as their deity.
So where Jesus is depicted as Lord of
this earth, those verses are
systematically
eradicated from the Bible.
Revelation 14:5
and in their mouth no lie was found for
they are spotless. NIV no lie was found
in their mouth. They are blameless. King
James and in their mouth was found no
guile for they are without fault before
the throne of God. You see here is a an
accountability
towards a higher power. Here there is no
accountability. There could be an
accountability to yourself. It means
nothing here. It is important who rules.
Revelation 22:14
is a radical change.
Blessed are those who wash their robes.
I hope they use the right soap powder.
I don't know what brands you have here,
but maybe it makes a difference.
Revelation 22:14
says, "Blessed are they that do his
commandments, that they may have the
right to the tree of life." Now, which
one do you think is probably right
here? There's no accountability.
And uh what are you washing your robes
with?
What are you rushing your robes with?
Blessed are they that do his
commandments. That's obedience. Let's
change that. In the RSV, in the NIV, in
the ASV, let's get rid of it. Luke 4
verse 8. And Jesus answered and said
unto him,"Get thee behind me, Satan, for
it is written, "Thou shalt worship the
Lord thy God, and him only shalt thou
serve." Well, the due which is basically
the Jesuit Bible or the product of the
Jesuit Bible. And Jesus answered said to
him, "It is written, thou shalt adore
the Lord thy God, and him only shalt
thou serve." What's gone?
Something's gone. RSV, same thing. And
Jesus answered, "It is written, you
shall worship the Lord your God, and him
only shall you serve." The NIV. Jesus
answered, "It is written, worship the
Lord your God and serve him only." All
of them leave something out. What do
they leave out?
Get ye behind me, Satan. Now, why why
they leave that out? The expression,
"Get ye behind me, Satan," was early
omitted because Jesus used the same
expression later to Peter in Matthew
16:23 to rebuke the apostle. And we
wouldn't want the same spirit to be
confused here. And this has to do with
the doctrine of Peter becoming
eventually a pope. It's quite a complex
issue, but uh there's a good reason why
they took it out. Acts 13:42,
Sabbath. Now notice this subtle little
change. This is very important for those
who keep the seventh day Sabbath. King
James. And when the Jews were gone out
of the synagogue, the Gentiles besought
that these words might be preached to
them the next Sabbath.
Now remember that this is all based on
Greek documents. The words are there.
These are changes that were made by
these individuals for a purpose. The
duea which was again this one based on
the Jesuit Bible. And as they as they
went out, they desired them that on the
next Sabbath they would speak unto them
these words. The RSV does the same
thing. As they went out, the people
begged that these things might be told
to them the next Sabbath. The NIV says,
"As Paul and Barnabas were leaving the
synagogue, the people invited them to
speak further about these things on the
next Sabbath."
You see, in the King James it says, "And
when the Jews were gone out of the
synagogue," what does that mean?
It means that he was preaching to the
Jews, and then the Gentiles came and
said, "Will you preach this to us next
Sabbath?" That means that the Gentiles
were willing to come on the Sabbath.
Now, if you take the Jews out there,
then it's not Saturday necessarily. If
it's just they, it could be an
ecumenical meeting, and Sabbath could
then be any day. But linking it to the
Jews, which day would it definitely be?
Saturday. It would definitely be
Saturday. So, a subtle little change.
These guys are so thorough. Do you think
this is a slip of the pen?
I don't think so. Now, this one gets
even worse. Very slight change, but very
succinct. Acts 16 verse 7. After they
were come to Msia, they said to go to
Binia, but the spirit suffered them not.
The dua. And when they come to Msia, da
da da da. And the spirit of Jesus
suffered them not. Their RSV does the
same thing. the spirit of Jesus and the
NIV does the same thing. The spirit of
Jesus. Now why you see you have to
understand the occult mind to understand
this one.
What happens here is the spirit that's
the spirit of God tells them no here it
is now the spirit of Jesus which implies
that the spirit is in control of Jesus.
Are you with me? The new age teaches
that when Jesus was one of the initiated
masters that came to this earth, he
didn't have power to do it right. So, he
was overshadowed by Matraa who used him
like a puppet. That's what they teach
here. The same idea comes out. Jesus is
controlled by the spirit and the spirit
tells them what to do. Here the
implication is the spirit says no. And
if Jesus is the one who said no, then he
and the spirit are one.
One Corinthians 5:7,
purge out therefore the old leven that
you may be a new lump as you are unleven
for even Christ our Passover is
sacrificed for us. The dua,
for Christ our pash is sacrificed. The
RSV, for Christ our pasha lamb has been
sacrificed. The NIV, for Christ our
Passover lamb has been sacrificed. Big
deal.
What's gone
for us? You see the exclusivity of Jesus
has to go.
Sad state of affairs. The phrase through
his blood is not found in either the
Jesuit or American resi revised version.
Its omission can be traced to Oregon 200
AD who expressly denies that either the
body or soul of our Lord was offered as
the price of our redemption. Now we must
understand something here. The
occultists teach that Jesus never really
died for you.
The occultists teach that Jesus had a
esoteric body. He didn't come in the
flesh. Now, the Bible teaches that he
who says that Jesus didn't come in the
flesh is Antichrist.
The occultists teach that when he hung
on the cross, he just appeared to hang
there for the Jews and that God whisked
him away before he died. So, he never
died a vicarious death for you. You
understand the difference? So, here we
have the same idea. He was not
sacrificed for us because esoterically
he never died for you because you don't
need a savior. You save yourself. You
are God. This is arrogance of the
highest degree.
The power of God is denied. 1 Peter
1:22. Seeing you have purified your
souls in obeying the truth through the
spirit unto unfeigned love of the
brethren. See that you love one another
with a pure heart fervently. The RSV
says, "Having purified your souls by
your obedience,
your obedience to the truth for a
sincere love of the brethren, for one
another, blah blah blah." NIV. Now that
you have purified yourselves by obeying
the truth, so that you have sincere love
for your brothers, love one another
deeply from the heart. You see, here the
obedience is something that you have
achieved through purification of
yourself. Here the obedience that you
have achieved has been made possible
through the inddwelling power of whom?
Of God. Through the spirit. Which one
would you prefer to be correct here?
Mind what you prefer? What do they
change here? It is not God. It is not
Christ in you that is working a change.
It is your own power. This is occult and
that is biblical.
2 Timothy 4:1 I charge thee therefore
before God and the Lord Jesus Christ who
shall judge the quick and the dead
at his appearing. Now this is a very
important little change. Wow. One little
word by at one tiny little what
difference does it make? It makes the
world of difference
at his appearing in his kingdom. I
charge thee before God. And Jesus Christ
says that you who shall judge the living
and the dead by his coming and his
kingdom. RSV says the same by NIV says
in view of
hello. What does that imply?
This implies that the judgment takes
place when? When Jesus comes back. Jesus
is going to come back. What does the
other one imply? Implies something
totally different. Let's see. The King
James in this text fixes the great day
of judgment as occurring at the time of
his appearing and his kingdom. The
Jesuit and the revised versions and the
NIV and the all of the others place it
in the indefinite future anywhere. It
could happen at any time. In fact, Roman
Catholicism teaches a millennialism.
There is no millennium. The church
reigns as the kingdom. Important point,
which is also not biblical, of course.
So these things have to be changed to
bring it in line with Roman Catholic
thinking. Hebrews 7:21 King James for
those priests were made without an oath.
But this with an oath by him that says
unto him the Lord swear and will not
repent to priest forever after the order
of Malchisedc.
Okay. So Jesus was a priest of a
different order, of a higher order
because only Levites were allowed to be
priests. But Jesus was from the tribe of
Judah. And as a someone from the pride
of tribe of Judah, how could he be a
priest? But he was of a higher order of
the order of Mechisedc who was king of
Salem.
Now what's the Jew do? Thou art priest
forever.
Where's the rest? What does the RSV do?
Thou art priest forever.
What does the NIV do? You are a priest
forever
after the order of Malchisedcic is gone.
So Jesus hasn't got a higher priesthood.
Isn't that interesting? Did you know
that the Freemasons
when they are initiated are of the order
of Malchisedc?
Did you know that a Mormon is in when he
is initiated into the higher degrees
he's of the order of Melkiseetic? So he
stands higher than Jesus. That's
fascinating.
Okay. So let's make Jesus a little bit
less than what he should be. John 5:39.
Search the scriptures for in in them you
have eternal life.
You search the scriptures because you
think that in them you have eternal
life. The NIV. You diligently study the
scriptures because you think that by
them you possess eternal life. What's
the difference between them?
Here it is a command. Search the
scriptures.
Semicolon. For in them you think you
have eternal life. Here it is they who
are have the initiate. On this point the
Dublin review. Notice this. This is a
Catholic newspaper or a Catholic article
July 1881 says the following. But
perhaps the most surprising change of
all is John 5:39.
That's the one we just read. It is no
longer search the scriptures, but ye
search. And thus, Protestantism has lost
the very cause of its being.
So they knew what they were doing and
why they changed it. Because we believe
that you have to search the scriptures
to find eternal life. And here
Protestantism
is scrapped
because just they believed. A deadly
blow against miracles. John 2:1. This
beginning of miracles did Jesus in Canaa
of Galilee. RSV signs. NIV miraculous
signs, not miracles anymore. Jesus, what
Jesus did was a miracle. It's something
that no one else could do. Jesus was
special. He was different to anyone. He
was not a magician.
The word miracle is found singular and
plural. 32 times in the authorized
version of the New Testament. Alas, what
desolation has been wrought by the
revised? In 23 of these instances, the
word miracle has entirely disappeared.
In the case of the other nine, although
the term is used in the text, its force
is robbed by a weakening substitute in
the margin. our authorized Bible
vindicated by Professor Wilkinson.
Doctrine of conversion. Notice how this
is undermined in Matthew 18:2 and 3. And
Jesus said, "Except you be converted and
become as little children." And he said,
"Unless you turn and become like little
children." Turn to what?
NIV. Unless you change and become like
little children. Change how?
Conversion is a very strong term and
implies exactly what it means. Remove
it. Let's go a little deeper. Human
knowledge exalted above the divine word
of the by the revision. Without him,
says John 1:3 and4, was not anything
made that was made. In him was life. The
RSV puts in the margin,
without him was not anything made. That
which has been made was life in him.
Now these are subtle little changes. Now
let's just check out how it goes
further. No creation, evolution instead.
Hebrews 11:3,
King James, through faith we understand
that the worlds were framed by the word
of God.
The RSV says in the margin, by faith we
understand that the ages have been
framed by the word of God. Now it's
ages. Okay. The NIV does this. By faith,
we understand that the universe was
formed at God's command. Now, you will
say, you know, I really don't get it. It
doesn't look like such a big deal. Here
it's the worlds. There it's the
universe. You know, what's the big deal?
Well, let's go and find out what
Professor Hort had in mind when he
suggested this change. Let's ask him.
It's nice to go to the horse's mouth.
Well, Professor Hort on Wcott, what did
you say? Wescott writes in this
connection we see the full meaning of
the words used of creation in Hebrews
11:3
by faith we understand that the worlds
the ages the universe there's the NIV
word under the aspect of time
have been formed by the word of God the
whole sequence of life and time which we
call the world has been fitted together
by God's
one creative word included
harmonious unfolding on one plan of the
last issues of all that was made. That
which is in relation to him one act at
once is in relation to us. Oh, they
write so nauseatingly. But let me
continue. Evolution apprehended in
orderly succession. See what did he
believe in? He believed in evolution.
And if you believe in evolution, then
you have to change the word just so
subtly so you don't get the import of
the first version. Colossians 1:15 and
16. Who is the image of the invisible
God, the firstborn of every creature,
for by him were all things created.
That's pretty clear. No doubt, right?
Jesus did it. RSV, he is the image of
the invisible God, the firstborn of
creation. For in him all things were
created. Well, if we're all divine,
could be in us, too, right? The new
language of the revised and the judgment
of the revisers hinders the application
of these texts to a material creation as
in the King James and limits them as a
spiritual application to Christianity.
So there we go. Let's just change the
whole doctrine of creation. King James
Hebrews 1:2 by him also he made the
worlds. RSV through him also he made the
ages. NIV through whom he made the
universe. Now it's possible to
spiritualize creation. Subtle subtle
changes. Ephesians 3:9 really irritates
me.
The NIV says, "And to make plain to
everyone the administration of his this
mystery which for ages past was kept
hidden in God, who created all things."
What do you think the King James says?
Let's read it.
Who created all things? By Jesus Christ.
Away with Jesus Christ. Don't you think
there's a subtle attack on Jesus Christ
here? Or maybe not such a subtle attack,
right? Maybe it's a pretty blatant
attack on Jesus Christ,
but the spirit suffered them not. We've
had that already. The spirit of Jesus in
the margin. The due is like the revised
on this change. Milligan says, "Act
16:7, the striking reading of the spirit
of Jesus, not simply as in the
authorized version, the spirit implies
that the Holy Spirit had so taken
position of the person of the exalted
Jesus that he could be spoken of as the
spirit of Jesus." So this is the
exposition. This is what the experts
say. So that's exactly the change that
they wanted. Now remember that Hort
denied the atonement. They hated the
doctrine that Jesus Christ died for you
by the shedding of his blood. Colossians
1:14,
King James, in whom we have redemption
through his blood, even the forgiveness
of sins.
The Jesuit version, in whom we have
redemption, the remission of sins.
What's God
through his blood? Well, what's the RSV
say? In him we have redemption, the
forgiveness of sins. Strange. And the
NIV, in whom we have redemption, the
forgiveness of sins. That's the Jesuit
Bible. So basically, if you read the
NIV, you're reading the Jesuit Bible
through his blood gone.
Change in the doctrine.
For even Christ our Passover, is
sacrificed for us. We've had this text,
but I just want to show it to you again.
There it is. The 4S is removed in the
RSV and it's removed in the NIV. So no
difference.
One writer thus registers his
indignation upon the change made in this
passage. He writes here's Reverend Burks
and Dr. Warfield's collection of
opinions. Mad. Yes, I'm mad. He says
yes. And haven't I reason to be mad when
I find that grand old passage for even
Christ our Passover is sacrificed for
us. A passage which sounds the keyynote
of the whole doctrine of redemption
unnecessarily changed into for our
Passover also has been sacrificed even
Christ. And we have such changes
everywhere. They are I believe called
improvements
in style by their authors and certainly
by no one else. I like his style. This
guy's goto.
Yes, I agree with you 100%.
What about the sec doctrine of the
second coming of Christ?
Wouldn't it be interesting if they could
change that as well? Matthew 24:3, King
James. What shall be the sign of thy
coming and of the end of the world? RSV
in the margin. What shall be the sign of
thy presence and of the consumation of
the age? Okay, so Jesus doesn't have to
come with the clouds. You can just sort
of sneak around. Appear here, appear
there. If you hear he's here, if you
hear he's there, don't go. You know the
story. Let's go on. Philippians 3 20:21.
King James. Who shall change our vile
body
that it may be fashioned like unto his
glorious body? The RSV and the ASV
say, "Who shall fashion a new the body
of our humiliation that it may be
conformed to the body of his glory?" And
what's the difference between those two?
Why do they go to so much trouble to
make those changes? Well, let's ask
them. The change in us indicated by the
King James according to this and other
scriptures is a change that occurs only
at the second coming of Christ.
It is a physical change of tangible
reality. But the change called for by
the revised may occur at any time before
his coming or be continuous as you are
changing as you become more accustomed
to Christianity. It may be a change from
the abstract vices to abstract virtues.
See they've spiritualized the way the
coming of Christ. He comes in glory and
you are changed instantly. That's what
the Bible teaches. They don't like that.
They prefer reincarnation.
2 Thessalonians 2:2 is an interesting
one. That you be not soon shaken in mind
as that day of Christ is at hand.
That at hand means soon to come. Revised
now present. Aha. This implies that it
could actually be right there now. Has
already come says the NIV. So here again
subtle changes changing the story of the
second coming. Titus 2:13 King James
looking for that blessed hope and the
glorious appearing of the great God and
our savior Jesus Christ. Awaiting RSV
awaiting our blessed hope the appearing
of the glory of our great God and the
savior Jesus Christ. Do you notice the
subtle change? By changing the adjective
glorious
to the name noun glory, the revisers
have removed the second coming of Christ
from the text.
Now it's not he that comes. It is
something that could happen at any time.
Revelation 17, he cometh with the clouds
and all kindreds of the earth shall wail
because of him. Notice this change. King
James version because of him.
The revised he is coming with the clouds
and all the tribes of earth shall mourn
over him. Now what does it mean?
Remember that Hort said we'll change it
here a little bit. We'll change it there
a little bit. Bishop Wescott himself
states, "All the tribes of the earth
shall mourn over him in penitential
sorrow, and not as the authorized
version, shall wail because of him in
the present expectation of terrible
vengeance."
Aha. So now when Jesus comes, according
to this one, they will all say, "We're
sorry for what we did." And he'll say,
"Fine, my children. Come, you are all
saved."
Whereas in the previous one, there was a
judgment at the flood and there will be
a judgment at the end. Isn't that what
the Bible teaches? Yes or no? Aha. It's
gone. It's spiritualized away. Do you
have another chance? You know, again,
burn it off on the other side or
reincarnate again or whatever.
Dr. Alexander Roberts, a member of the
English New Testament Committee, is of
course for the change. What does he say?
Acts 3:1 19 and 20. An impossible
translation here occurs in the
authorized version which implies that
Jesus will come to judge the world. No,
we don't want that. He says, "Repent ye
therefore." And then he reads it again
and he says, "For esqueological reasons,
it is most important that the true
rendering of this passage should be
presented. It is thus given in the
revised version." So, we've changed it
so that there is no judgment when Jesus
comes. Nice. Thank you.
Most of the revisers did not believe
there would be a personal return of
Jesus before the restitution of all
things which the authorized rendering of
this passage teaches. So there's a whole
change of doctrine here. This is very
important if you believe in the advent
of Christ and what's going to happen.
Mark 7:1 19 because it enterth not in
the hearts but into the belly. Notice
this change. This is so vile. This
change so sneaky. because it enterth not
into his heart but into the belly and
goeth out in the draft. That means when
you go to the toilet, purging all meats,
foods. So basically the King James says
it doesn't go into the heart, it goes
into the stomach and it goes out and
then it's gone.
The RSV says since it enters not in his
heart but his stomach and so passes on.
Thus he declared all foods clean. Hello.
Where does he declare foods clean in
this one? Nowhere. Now let's read what
the NIV says. It gets even more blatant.
Boy, this is some change. For it doesn't
go into his heart, but into his stomach
and then out of his body. In saying
this, Jesus declared all foods clean.
Where does it say that?
Doesn't say it anywhere. So, we got a
whole new doctrine here. Okay.
Interesting.
So for those who really love the NIV,
you'll have a hard time proving some
interesting facts.
Luke 23:44 and 45 King James. And it was
about the sixth hour and there was
darkness over all the earth until the
9th hour and the sun was darkened. So
that was a miracle showing that Jesus
was the son of God. And here was a
celestial miracle. RSV says the sun's
light failed.
And the Moffett translation says owing
to an eclipse of the sun. I wonder where
they get that from.
So no miracle over here. 1 Corinthians
7:5 leaves out that you have to fast
sometimes or that fasting might be
beneficial. John 9:4, one little word
changed. Notice this how cute they are.
I must work the works of him that sent
me while it is day. The night cometh
when no man can work. the RSV and the
NIV says we must work the works of him
who sent me. What's the difference
between the two?
It's a massive difference in the one
Jesus is the only one who can do this
work here. We can all do it. I will show
you modern-day preachers in lectures to
come that stand up on the pulpit and say
they could have saved you just like
Jesus could. I'll show you preachers,
high ranking preachers in the world who
say that exact thing. And well, no
problem. We can use this text in the new
reversions to do that. One little change
here. 2 Timothy 4:1 I charge thee
therefore before God and the Lord Jesus
Christ who shall judge the quick and the
dead at his appearing very important
again and by his appearing that same
change where the doctrine of the coming
of Christ is changed one Corinthians
11:9
now here you have the whole question of
transsubstantiation
the whole mass story coming out for he
that eateth and drinkkeeth unworthily
eateth and drinkketh damnation to
himself, not discerning the Lord's body.
RSV for anyone who eats and drinks
without discerning the body eats and
drinks judgment upon himself. The
unworthy is gone and the Lord is gone.
The NIV
for anyone who eats and drinks without
recognizing the body of the Lord
eats and drinks judgment upon himself.
Wow. This this is Roman Catholicism.
This is a host. Here you have
transsubstantiation.
The omission of unworthy and Lord
therefore condemns Protestants who do
not believe that the bread has been
turned into the body of Christ. This is
a Jesuit Bible. The NIV is a Jesuit
Bible. Make no doubt. I used to read it
and I still have it on my shelf, but I
like to use it to show people the
changes. So don't throw them away. Keep
them. Make a whole series of them.
Now, what about the restoring the
confessional? Roman Catholicism
teaches the confessional. King James
says, "Confess your faults one to
another." The RSV, "Therefore, confess
your sins one to another." The NIV,
"Therefore, confess your sins to each
other."
The Dublin Review, this is a Catholic
newspaper, July 1881 says, "The apostles
have now power to forgive sins and not
simply to remit them. Confess your sins
is the new reading of James 5:16." So,
was it deliberate? Yes or no?
It was deliberate. It was very
deliberate. So, they can get the
confessional into the NIV. Hebrews
10:21, King James. and having a high
priest over the house of God.
An high priest.
RSV, a great priest. NIV, a great
priest.
Okay, that means it implies that there
can be other priests. If there is a
great priest, it implies there can be
priests that are not so great also
officiating. But and priest is one
priest. So now you can have a
priesthood. Very important. And this is
a bomber. I want you all to take note of
this text. Everyone sitting here. This
text is very important for you and it's
incredibly important for me.
The whole church government is changed
in Acts 15 23 the King James. And they
wrote letters by them after this manner.
The apostles and elders and brethren
send greetings unto the brethren. Okay.
Who sends these greetings and this
information? The apostles, the elders,
and the brethren send out the first
apostolic letter to the churches, the
RSV.
With the following letter the brethren
both the apostles and elders to the
brethren who are the Gentiles the NIV
with them they sent following letter the
apostles and elders comma your brothers
to the gentile believers what does this
do
this is very important all they've
changed is basically a comma that's all
they've done it's a very subtle change
but it's a mighty mighty mighty mighty
change and I'll tell you Why? Because
here you have three groups officiating
in the church. You have the apostles,
you have the elders, and you have the
brethren. And Peter says, "You are all
priests." Does Peter say that? Yes or
no? You are all priests. That's what
Peter says. Here you have two groups.
You have the apostles and the elders.
And then you have the brethren. Now,
what did they think about this? Here we
go. This passage is used as a foundation
on which to base an argument for a
clergy
separated by God in their function from
the lay brethren.
It makes a vast difference in sending
out this authorative letter from the
first council of the Christian church
whether it issued from the apostles and
elders only or whether it issued from
the apostles, elders and the brethren.
Here again to affect this change the
revisers omitted two Greek words.
So they changed it by leaving out two
Greek words and now they have the
apostles and the elders and then they
have the brethren. Have you heard people
say you should not be preaching this?
You're not a theologian.
Have you heard that? What right of have
you to stand and preach the word of God?
You are not a theologian. I tell you I
have heard that many, many times in my
life. I'm not a theologian. No, I'm a
brethren.
And so are all of you brethren. And you
have the right to preach the word of God
because you are priests of the most
high. To change it and you are have no
right to preach you are not a theologian
is Jesuit teaching. It's from the pits
of hell. It's not biblical
and everybody is a priest of God. So
ignore them when they say you're not a
theologian. You have the right to read
the word of God. just as they have the
right to read the word of God. Very
important changes and they irritate me.
This name then of priest and priesthood
properly so-called as St. Augustine
said, here we go back to the church
fathers, which is an order distinct from
the leoty and vulgar people
ordained to offer Christ in an unbloody
manner in the sacrifice to his heavenly
father for us to preach and minister the
sacraments and to be the pastors of the
people they wholly suppress in their
translations.
See the point? Augustine says we are
holy priesthood and you are just profane
rubbish. We'll tell you what to believe.
No, no, no. The Bible says no such
thing. And that early letter very
important. Hebrews 9 27. And as it is
appointed unto men once to die, but
after this the judgment. That's pretty
clear. RSV. And just as it is appointed
for men to die once and after this comes
judgment. NIV to die once and after this
to face judgment. Now let's ask these
people what the change meant. Canon
farah claims the change was deliberate.
And Canon Farah ought to know because he
was a member of the apostles club.
Remember that club that Hort belonged to
that secret society. Farah said in this
change there is a positive certainty
that it does not mean the judgment in
the sense in which that word is
popularly understood by abandoning the
article which King James translators
here incorrectly inserted the revisers
help as they have done in so many other
places silently to remove de-seated
errors. Well, you're an apostle up there
but an apostle of another kind. I
believe at the death of each of us there
follows a judgment. As the sacred writer
says, the judgment, the final judgment
may not be for centuries to come in the
omission of that unauthorized little
article from the authorized version by
the revisers no lies no less a doctrine
than that of the existence of an
intermediate state. Aha. So by leaving
out the little article, you've got
purgatory in your Bible. You can prove
purgatory, but you cannot prove it is
once to die and then the judgment. Luke
17:2, to perform the mercy promised to
our fathers. Revised and the NIV to show
mercy to our fathers. Now, this is
interesting.
This is fascinating. Now, you can show
mercy to our fathers. So, I can pray for
the dead. Can I now pray for the dead?
Apparently, yes. The text was one which
if rendered literally no one could read
without being convinced that at least
sus suspected that the fathers already
dead needed mercy and that the Lord God
of Israel was prepared to perform it to
them. But where were those fathers? Not
in heaven where mercy is swallowed up in
joy and assuredly not in hell of the dam
where mercy could not reach them. They
must therefore have been in a place
between both or neither the one nor the
other. What? In limbo or purgatory? Why
certainly in one or the other. So now we
have purgatory in the Bible. Did you
know that it was there? If you have a
modern translation, you can prove
purgatory. Tremendous. The bishop
further claims that the revisers in
making this change vindicated the Jesuit
New Testament of 1582 and convicted the
King James of perversion.
Right? Jesuit Bible. 1 Peter 4:6. For
this cause was the gospel preached also
to them that are dead.
RSV for this is why the gospel was
preached even to the dead. NIV gets even
worse. For this is the reason the gospel
was preached even to those who are now
dead.
Now what does that mean? Well, here the
gospel was it preached to those who are
dead? Sure. In the past, the gospel was
preached to those that are dead. Now,
here it is still being preached to the
dead. Acts 24:15,
"And there shall be a resurrection of
the dead." But the RSV says, "There will
be a resurrection for both the just and
the unjust." Huh? So, when you are dead,
you are dead and then you will rise
according to the King James, but not
according to the others. Now, you can be
a ghost. So let's see if we can find
ghost theology. Job 19 26. The NASV
says, "Even after my flesh is flayed,
yet without my flesh I shall see God."
So how do you see God? Now as a spook.
Casper the friendly ghost. That's how
you will see him. What does the King
James say? And though after my skin
worms destroy this body, yet in my flesh
shall I see God. That's a big
difference. The one is a resurrection.
The other one is not. Job 26:5. Dead
things are formed under the waters and
the inhabitants thereof. The revised
they the shades margin. They are
deceased. Tremble beneath the waters and
the inhabitants thereof. This is
fascinating. This is complicated stuff.
In the first one over here, dead things
are formed from under the waters and the
inhabitants thereof. So dead things are
down there. The revised now the deceased
tremble underneath the waters. So
there's something like hell or purgatory
or something. The NIV gets more blatant.
The dead are in deep anguish. Those
beneath the waters and all that live in
them. Wow. So now we have somebody
burning down there in purgatory. So the
NIV again teaches a totally unbiblical
doctrine. King James, the Lord knoweth
how to deliver the godly out of
temptation and to reserve the unjust
unto the day of judgment to be punished.
Look what the NIV says. Unrighteously
for the day of judgment while continuing
their punishment. What have we got here?
You know, these Bibles are disgusting as
far as I'm concerned. They are
disgusting. They are teaching a totally
different doctrine here. The different
regions of conscious dead as Roman
Catholics teach supported by the revised
King James. And all that dwell upon the
earth shall worship him whose names are
not written in the book referring to the
beast. Now that is of the lamb slain
from the foundations of the world. Here
the lamb was slain from the foundations
of the world. The RSV and all that dwell
on earth will worship it. Everyone whose
names have not been written before the
foundations of the world. It's the
people whose names have been written
before the foundations in the book of
life of the lamb.
The King James in 1 Corinthians 15:34
says, "He rose again on the third day."
The revised said, "He hath been raised
on the third day." What's the difference
between the two?
The difference is in the one he has
power within himself to rise from the
dead and in the other one he gets raised
because he's inferior to God. That's the
difference.
1 Corinthians 11:24
very interesting the mass he broke it
and he said take eat this is my body
which is broken. The RSV and when he had
given thanks he broke it and said this
is my body which is for you do this in
remembrance of me. Now we have a host.
We have a literal body. So this is
Catholic doctrine. That is not
Christ is with us always not in person
but by his spirit. The revisers doctrine
of the incarnation. The mass therefore
makes unnecessary and destroys the truth
that he shall come to the second time
without sin unto salvation. Hebrews
9:28.
Cardinal Wiseman exalts that the
revision movement vindicated the
Catholic Bible. Look what he says. When
we consider the scorn cost by the
reformers upon the Vulgate and their
recurrence in consequence to the Greek
as the only accurate standard, we cannot
but rejoice at the silent triumph which
truth has at length gained over the
clamorous error. For in fact, the
principal writers who have avenged the
Vulgate and obtained for it its critical
preeminence are Protestants.
Wow. I wonder whether they were
Protestants. I think they were Jesuits
disguised as Protestants because that's
what we saw in the previous lecture. And
we have similar statements here from the
Reverend Thomas. The brief examination
which I've been able to make of the
revised version of the New Testament has
convinced me that the committee have
labored with great sincerity and
diligence and that they have produced a
translation much more correct than
general received amongst the
Protestants. So he says it is in line
with the Catholic version and confirms
the correctness of our Bible. There we
go. So all these changes have been made.
Catholic magazine claims the revised
version is the death nail of
Protestantism.
Protestantism is going to go. The
destruction of their temple that Chakina
departed from the holy of holies. So
perhaps it is to be with the English
Bible the temple of Protestantism. It's
going to be destroyed. It's going to go.
The revives had a wonderful opportunity.
They might have made a few changes, says
the Protestant journal, but they blew
it. They destroyed it. One question I
have for you. Is Jesus a liar?
King James version, John 7:8. Go ye up
into the feast. I go not up yet unto the
feast, for my time is not yet full come.
RSV, go to the feast yourselves. I'm not
going up to this feast for my time has
not yet fully come. Here Jesus says, I'm
not going, but he went. Here Jesus says,
I'm not yet going. And then he went. So
here he's telling the truth and there's
a liar. You choose whether you want
Jesus to be a liar or whether you don't
want to him to be a liar. The greatest
damage of all is when you take away the
deity of Christ. And for that we will
wait for the next session. Thank you.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.